live from Los Angeles the Academy of
Motion Picture Arts and Sciences
presents Oscar the 66th annual Academy
Awards
brought to you by redline revolutionary
products for revolutionary women the
American Express card don't leave home
without it
JCPenney doing it right and coca-cola
always the real thing always coca-cola
while the 66th year will be bands have
been gathering since early morning who's
sharing the excitement of the Academy
Awards here at the Dorothy Chandler
Pavilion in California you're invited to
join them as the film community
celebrates Oscar night
addition to the oscar cast and a percent
of this evening christian slater this
dedicated actress will be a present of
this evening madeleine stowe new film
star a nominee for original song Janet
Jackson
find young actor also a presenter
tonight Nicolas Cage
at age 12 already a Hollywood veteran
Elijah Wood double-dominant tinnitus
actress and supporting actress Holly
Hunter Oscar winner presenting tonight
Geena Davis in her handsome husband
director Renny Harlin 19 ID Oscar winner
of reversal of fortune Jeremy Irons
Supporting Actor nominee for in the name
of the Potter heat hustle wave
nominee tonight for Best Actress for her
portrayal of Tina Turner Angela Bassett
a Mambo King in one of the stars of
Philadelphia Antonio Banderas first-time
Oscar nominee for his performance in
Schindler's List Liam Neeson she returns
tonight for the fourth time is Oscar
choreographer Debbie Allen and her
husband nor Nixon returning once again
to the Oscars show tonight she'll be a
presenter Sharon Stone five-time Oscar
nominees starring on stage and Sunset
Boulevard Glenn Close twice nominated
for Supporting Actor in 1991 and now
Tommy Lee Jones
a glamorous Hollywood couple both of
whom will be presenters on tonight's
Oscar cast Nicole Kidman and Tom Cruise
from the accounting firm of Price
Waterhouse in tabulate the ballots and
guarantee the secrecy of the results mr.
Diane Lyle and mr. Frank Johnson last
year's winner for Best Actress in a
double nominee tonight Emma Thompson
last year's winner for Best Supporting
Actor Gene Hackman heavy favorite her
Oscar recognition Steven Spielberg
accompanied by his wife actress Kate
Capshaw 1977 Oscar winner for the
goodbye girl Richard Dreyfuss with Rosie
O'Donnell
oscar-winner for supporting actress and
cactus flower and her leading man Goldie
Hawn and Kurt Russell first-time nominee
for Supporting Actress in a work in
fearless Rosie Perez
British actor nominated for Schindler's
List tonight grapevines
last year's Oscar winner for Best Actor
8-time Oscar nominee el vecino
Oscar winner for my left foot nominated
again tonight Daniel day-lewis